last week coca-cola announced its
changing diet cokes appearance and taste
in an attempt to appeal to Millennials
this is real check it out that's their
new look yes because they want to get
Millennials drinking the diet coke or
and they thought that that would appeal
to those kids like colors kids like
colors well guess well the diet coke is
not the only the only ones doing this
turns out a lot of companies are trying
to update their products for younger
generations for example check out the
new Quaker Oats guy I just saw this and
it really Wow freaked me out a little
bit yeah then check it out there's
there's the new X lakhs box right and it
says post your poop pics on Instagram
and we'll hover boy boy the hell is that
all about I think yeah laughs don't need
an incentive to post my d yeah and also
a is it laxative and a hoverboard really
a good llamó propel you forward I don't
know hey Kellogg's has updated Tony the
Tiger I thought that was pretty
impressive he's uh
[Applause]
yeah I didn't know that's where the
nipples were on a time you know that's
exactly where the nipples are there's
the new grape-nuts check out the new
Grape Nuts right there that well I like
to get my condoms
finally check out the hip new Morton
Salt box that's
[Applause]
you